♪ ♪
>> Bret: YOU MAY SOON SEE IN
PRICES ON ADVERTISEMENTS FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, AND I WOULD
BE A MAJOR CHANGE FROM THE DRUG
INDUSTRY AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
VERY MUCH AGAINST IT.
SOME ARE FOR IT TO TRY TO DRIVE
DRUG PRICES DOWN, LET'S TALK
ABOUT IT.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR COMING.
>> IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE.
>> Bret: WHAT DOES THE
PROPOSAL?
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
PROPOSING IS THAT DRUG COMPANIES
WOULD HAVE TO PUT THE LIST PRICE
OF THEIR DRUGS AND THEIR TV ADS.
THAT WAY PEOPLE KNOW HOW MUCH A
DRUG COST WHEN THEY GO TO SEE
THEIR DOCTOR AND WHETHER IT IS A
$50 DRUG, OR A $5,000 DRUG.
THEY CAN FACTOR THAT INTO THE
DISCUSSION THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
WITH HER DOCTORS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID IN MAY HE
WANTED TO BRING THIS KIND OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO THE DRUG INDUSTRY SO THAT HE
COULD BRING DRUG PRICES DOWN.
HE IS DELIVERING ON THAT TODAY.
>> Bret: IN ADDITION TO THE
GUYS WHO TALKS FAST AT THE END
OF THE COMMERCIAL AND SAYS COME
ALL THESE BAD THINGS CAN HAPPEN
TO YOU, BY THE WAY, IT CAN COST
$5,000.
>> IT WILL SAY THE RIGHT
IMPRINTS.
THE MONTHLY COST OF THIS THERAPY
WHERE THE COURSE OF THERAPY.
>> Bret: THE PURPOSE BEING,
COMPETITION?
>> THE PURPOSE IS COMPETITION,
THE PURPOSE IS THE PATIENT AND
THE DRIVER'S SEAT WHO IS
KNOWLEDGEABLE WITH CRITICAL
INFORMATION.
WHERE ELSE IN OUR WORLD TO BE GO
IN AND TRY TO MAKE A PURCHASING
DECISION AND WE DON'T KNOW THE
PRICE OF THE PRODUCT?
WE ARE BRINGING THAT
TRANSPARENCY.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION, THEY HAVE FOUGHT
US, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS.
HE BELIEVES THE PATIENT OUGHT TO
BE AT THE CENTER AND HAVE THIS
INFORMATION AND DRUG PRICES HAVE
TO COME DOWN.
>> Bret: THIS MIDTERM
ELECTION, DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING
ON THE ISSUE OF HEALTH CARE.
DRUG PRICES AS WELL, NUMBER TWO
ON HEALTH CARE, SHOULD THE
GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE MORE?
64%.
BOX THREE, PRESIDENT'S HANDLING
OF HEALTH CARE, APPROVE OR
DISAPPROVE?
38% APPROVE, WHICH PARTY WOULD
DO A BETTER JOB ON HEALTH CARE?
DEMOCRATS 49%, TO REPUBLICANS
44%.
>> ARIZONANS, THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THEIR HEALTH CARE.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T HAVE BEDS AND
THOSE WHO DO ARE PAYING TOO MUC
MUCH.
>> IT IS LESS EXPENSIVE THAN THE
WAY WE PAY OR FAIL TO PAY
HEALTH CARE IN THIS STATE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> WE SAID THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN MEDICARE COVERAGE FOR THE
ELDERLY, THAT DOES NOT RATE JUST
LIVE.
WE EXPAND COVERAGE TO INCLUDE
TONTO CARE, VISION CARE AND
CHEERING.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
SENIORS.
>> Bret: TAUGHT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POINT OF VIEW,
WHY VOTERS SHOULD HANDEDLY BE
TIME                  HAND YOU T
TIME                  HAND YOU E
TIME                  HAND YOU B
TOWN?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO
MAKING HEALTH CARE
MORE AFFORDABLE AND BRING MORE
CHOICE, MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
GIVE THE PATIENT TO THE DRIVER'S
SEAT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROMISING
MEDICARE FOR ALL, THAT IS ONE OF
THE BIG IDEAS ALL.
PEOPLE KEEP TALKING ABOUT THAT.
MEDICARE ALL IS MEDICARE FOR
NON.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
BROUGHT YOU OBAMACARE.
THIS TIME THEY'RE NOT EVEN
MAKING THE PROMISE THAT YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR HEALTH PLAN OR YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR.
THEY KNOW THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
THE 178 MILLION OF US WHO HAVE
EMPLOYEE INSURANCE, THAT WOULD
GO AWAY UNDER SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS.
YOUR DOCTOR, HE WOULD GET TO
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR BECAUSE YOUR
DOCTOR WOULD BELIEVE THESE RATES
WE WOULD HAVE A TWO TIER SYSTEM
OF HEALTH CARE WHERE THEY MOVE
INTO A CASH SYSTEM OUTSIDE OF
THIS MEDICARE.
AMERICAN SENIORS WOULD LOSE HER
DOCTORS, THEIR HOSPITALS, THE
CARE.
>> Bret: THE DEMOCRATS OF THAT
THAT IS ALL SCARE TACTICS, U.S.
PEOPLE AND THEY ARE AFRAID OF
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION DOING
NOW WITH CONGRESS WERE WITHOUT
CONGRESS TO CHANGE THE DYNAMIC?
>> THE PRESENT HAS BEEN SO
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO BRING
HEALTH CARE COSTS DOWN, WHETHER
IT IS A DRUG COSTS.
OR IN HEALTH INSURANCE, WE ARE
DEALING WITH A FAILED OBAMACARE
PROGRAM.
THE FIRST TIME EVER OBAMACARE
PLANS OF THE BENCHMARK PREMIUM
IS TEN ALMOST 2% UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEADERSHIP
BECAUSE HE STABILIZE THE MARKET.
IT IS STILL UNAFFORDABLE, I DO
STILL INSURANCE PEOPLE DON'T
NECESSARILY WANT BUT HE IS AT
LEAST ABLE LIES IN THE PRICE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO CAMPAIGNED
TO GET RID OF OBAMACARE IS DOING
A BETTER JOB MANAGING OBAMACARE
THAN THEY BUY WHO WROTE THE
BILL.
>> Bret: ONE MORE QUESTION,
THE PRESIDENT AND THE INTERVIEW
SUGGESTED THAT THE SEPARATION
POLICY IS UNDER REVIEW WITH
PARENTS AND CHILDREN.
DO YOU KNOW WHERE THAT STANDS?
>> >> OUR IMMIGRATION POLICIESA
>> >> OUR IMMIGRATION POLICIESE
COMPLETELY BROKEN IN THIS
COUNTRY AND CONGRESS HAS GOT TO
ACT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS CALLED ON
CONGRESS TO FIX THIS BROKEN
SYSTEM.
WHAT WE DO IS RECEIVE CHILDREN
WHO COME INTO THIS COUNTRY
UNACCOMPANIED, MIGRANT CHILDREN
WHO COME IN HERE ILLEGALLY.
THEY ARE GIVEN TO US TO PROVIDE
A SAFE AND SECURE ENVIRONMENT
AND WHAT WE DO IS WE WORK TO
FIND THE DIVIDED SPONSORS,
USUALLY THESE ARE FAMILY MEMBERS
ALREADY IN THE COUNTRY WHILE
THEY AWAIT THEIR ADJUDICATION  J
THEY AWAIT THEIR ADJUDICATION  D
THEY AWAIT THEIR ADJUDICATION  C
THEY AWAIT THEIR ADJUDICATION  A
THEY AWAIT THEIR ADJUDICATION  Y
LETTER.
WE HAVE 13,000 UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THIS BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM THAT DOES
DRUG USE CHILDREN TO COME INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY MAKE THIS HORRIBLE JOURNEY
TO TRY TO GET THEM INTO THIS
COUNTRY AND THE COMMON ILLEGALLY
THEY ARE GIVEN INTO OUR CUSTODY
AND WE HAVE TO FIND A PLACE TO
PUT THEM.
>> Bret: WITH THEIR PARENTS?
>> NO, THEY COME UNACCOMPANIED.
THESE 13,000 ARE KIDS WHO COME